[Music]  she's tracked okay okay okay  how many can you save 11 species blues  the last of her kind if you'll never  capture her we thought you might know  someone who could help a rescue op what  could go wrong  hey blue  you know me come with me hey no you  can't stay here right now  it was on the lot  the man who proved Raptors can follow  orders you never thought how many  millions a trained predator might be  woods  they're gonna sell them not blue they  need it for something else this is the  most dangerous creature that ever walked  the earth I say we shut this whole thing  down  hey girl you think what I'm thinking  genetic power has now been unleashed  you can't put it back in the box  if I don't make him back  remember you're the one who made me come  here I'll be all right  these creatures were here before us and  if we're not careful they're gonna be  Hereafter welcome to Jurassic world  [Music]  [Music]